how many different revenue streams did
you create with billboard and all the
coke a merchandise the webseries the
radio station live events the film
sponsorship six okay which one was the
most difficult to make it work no not
really no I mean I mean you know like
like cuz we're still we're still in
release you know like we're still
getting things out there and the thing
is to it's a matter of there's no
there's no like rhyme or reason anymore
there's no rules you know it's
interesting cuz they're still
gatekeepers a lot of gatekeepers like
we're having a hell of a time booking
theaters even though we've made money
you know those gatekeepers at film
festivals not to say that I want to get
into film festivals
there's gatekeepers every step of the
way and you just have to figure out a
way to get around them you know just
like when we should tag
you know subways in New York you know we
still got a way around them they'll do
these sorts of things but it just it's
like it's like you know but you're
there's gatekeepers that's probably the
biggest challenge for indie filmmakers
right now but in terms of the different
sorts of revenue streams like we're
still we're still in it we're still
making money you know so it's like it's
a and then we're just started like we're
just getting this thing out there now
like people are just starting to find
out about it yeah so which is kind of
exciting so you know we've made money
and sponsorship we've made money and
merch you know you know we've made money
you know out of that it's like yeah so
it's working it's funny because you said
the gatekeepers and there's like two
catchphrases with any film and that is
the K keepers are no longer in control
and you have to build your audience and
that's really interesting that you say
that the gatekeepers still they still
exist oh absolutely they do can you
challenge that a little bit yeah sure so
oh god we're going to start with film
festivals for instance there's
gatekeepers and realized - it's like you
know everybody wants get into the big
film festivals and the thing is is
people have to realize that they program
a certain way every year and that
having changes and so what might have
gotten into festival X in 2015 is not
going to get into festival X in 2016 and
that's a thing so the sensibilities
change so those are gatekeepers that you
are unaware of how things change right
and so and there's a lot of backroom
politicking going on a lot of it and I'm
so far outside the system that I don't
even play in the pole the politics I
don't know them you know it's there's
gatekeepers in press
there's gatekeepers are trying to get
press there's there's gatekeepers in
terms of trying to get reviews you know
unless you're worthy or something on
those lines will you get reviewed by
like a major outlet you know then the
theaters have gatekeepers like you know
if you own a theater they then have a
book or that they put as a diversion you
know and and so like okay you got to
appeal to the Booker okay the Booker
likes that you have to be appealed with
to the theater and so there's all these
you have any much at all business people
right so they're all business people
trying to do the best they can for their
own individual businesses and people
like us creative look at them as like
you know gatekeepers right but just a
matter of having sensibility and if you
can plead your case and and understand
what you are selling that's a big leg up
and actually not necessarily under let
them know what you were doing but what
you can do for them the big thing is
it's like it's like you know when you
know I now go to like film festivals I
often end up you know having some sort
of talkback or some sort of educational
thing because people are intrigued of
like how I do what I do and you know
that's selling point for me you know
that that separates me from my peers you
know in terms of film festivals it all
depends on what their programming and
it's really hard but again it's it there
there's gatekeepers I add on the house
explain it and and it's also - it's like
I'm not coming down at critics by any
means because the industry needs them
but the interesting is is because so
many budgets have been cut from media
outlets that as fewer and fewer and
they can only cover so many things but
people like me get frustrated by that
and that we don't that doesn't come to
mind right away and you wonder why the
hell they are like looking at my you
know my piece you know or they're not
understanding it you know and and and
there's some really like awesome
reviewers out there I'm not saying that
there's not but at the same time it's a
matter of like somebody that's small
that's a first time out it's gonna be
very hard to get you know recognition
which is which is a shame it's really
interesting yeah that you say that that
the gatekeeping still exist even in this
realm I think so many people think Oh
independent filmmaking and you can be
outside the system you can do whatever
you want but no I make money you can try
to wear how you want
how you gonna make money honestly I mean
it comes down to it if you can't book a
theater you're not going to make well I
get it if you want to go into theaters I
mean because there's so many different
business models I think that's probably
what they're saying there's no more geek
a brute gatekeepers cuz there's all
these different business models but when
when push comes to shove you still have
to make money and so you have to figure
out how to facilitate that like right
now we're having how all the time trying
to get press straight up you know and
and even though I'm doing stuff
different even though I've got an
interesting story to tell and it's just
a matter of you know maybe I'm too
assertive I don't know but it's just a
matter of like one of those things it's
just it's been a challenge you know and
and I don't know what to say maybe I'm
not pres worthy I don't know well you
know film school covered you which is I
would say that that's an acclaim right
there
great great site so no I'll be honest I
wrote the article ah okay okay but they
allowed you to have it there the piece
that I wrote true that's gonna be
published by a major outlet as well okay
but the weird thing about it is like
it's like I'm the one writing about what
I'm doing they're not having somebody
cover it so you notice shared I mean
like so so like because I have written
before and I've been published before
and yada yada yada so like I guess that
does mean something but I've got to be
honest with people like yeah I'm not
gonna say like oh yeah they carved me
isn't that great I covered me
hmm they're just the outlet and and and
again it's like it's like you're anybody
can reach out to me and I'll get you
straight you know and and that's a thing
it's a matter of of yes it's an honor
and and and I appreciate them for doing
it I really do
cuz we wouldn't have got in an otherwise
you know and but it's just it's just
true I don't I don't know what to say
it's it's the truth of the matter I
think it's good that people hear that
even if your quote independent it's not
it's not as independent as one would
think
so no and it's like it's like you know
ever you yeah the thing about it too
it's like how are these critics or these
or these publications making money right
you know they're selling advertising and
so they're only can sell so much
advertising that they have so much
readership it's just one reason why to
is I think a lot of the normal India
outlets are going more and more
mainstream because if you appeal to the
widest audience possible so they can
then have the readership so they can
charge more money for their ads you have
to go with money goes I don't know how
else to say it
you know it's an everybody has their own
business models and I understand that at
the same time does it mean that you know
I had you know there was a I saw a
couple films of a slam dances past year
that were just outstanding films that
probably are never gonna see the light
of day we're just so sad you know
because the filmmakers busted their
butts getting them there you know I
liked him I could find them a market car
let's say I get a ship with their films
for them I know I could and make money
for them but I don't over citing whether
or not I want to go into that business
and and the ads it's like is knowing all
the all the other BS I've got to go
through to be able to make them
successful do you think the politics
exist because you're not in Los Angeles
or you don't think that has anything to
do know it does absolutely it does yeah
because it's so funny because when I go
to film festivals people from New Yorker
think I'm from LA people from LA thing
up from New York and then when I say I'm
from Allentown PA they're like what the
hell are you doing in Allentown let me
tell them you know my family you know I
tell them the history of enlike oh you
think I'm Allentown that you know so it
does differentiate me from the pack
in us too as my projects are so
authentic because I don't listen to
stuff going on around me because there
isn't any
you only mean there's not many
filmmakers in Allentown and so but at
the same time I'm not you know going out
to cocktail parties or things that know
what's going on you know down the street
right now we're in LA it's like you know
what I mean so it's like and so I'm so
removed and that is a problem because I
I can't rub elbows with people and and
that's my own problem that's my own
fault it's my own challenge it's a
matter of like I need to be present more
and I think that you know more people
knew what I was doing and I was more
positioned I guess you would say I could
be more successful but it just is nature
of the beast
you